ainsi des luminances et de mettre en
valeur les jeunes martiniquais qui
réussissent sur l'île et dans le monde
entier
voilà le but c'est vraiment de mettre en
lumière ces jeunes dans leurs activités
respectives
comment votre association organise
détection de ces jeunes nous recensons
l'opération alors il faut savoir qu'à
une période où les jeunes eux mêmes
peuvent candidater
en téléchargeant dossier sur nos
plateformes néanmoins on a aussi le
principe ou quelqu'un tierces peut
présenter un candidat à cet événement le
principe retenu c'est de mettre en avant
les jeunes comme le candidat de
sectionner pour l'instant cette édition
mais s annonce très bien ça donc on a eu
énormément de qualités au niveau des
candidatures de un peu partout dans le
monde on a des candidats qui habite à
boston d'autres à londres d'autres en
martinique
d'autres sur paris sur la métropole donc
pour l'instant les luminaires édition
2010 est s'annonce très bien de manière
qualitative et d'ailleurs on remercie
tous ses candidats pour pour cesser de
nous avoir montré dans leur savoir faire
et leurs activités il y à bien une
dizaine de catégories
ce concours on nous avait effectivement
une dizaine de catégories
on a dans l'économie on a entreprise
innovante jeunes entrepreneurs on a
aussi tout ce qui touche au tourisme
donc que ce soit des actions positives
ou que ce soit des initiatives
touristiques pour lille nous avons aussi
la catégorie musiciens chanteurs donc
voilà donc on est très polyvalent dans
les catégories alors le public on
appelle le public à voter déjà pour l'or
pour les candidats à partir du mardi 12
les besoins jusqu'au 12 juillet il ya
possibilité de voter pour leurs
candidats préférés via la plateforme
lumine atv et le soir même de la
cérémonie donc il s'agit du 22 juillet à
tropiques atrium nous saurons enfin qui
sont les lauriers les lauréats des
différentes catégories
ils sont devenus les les précédents
lauréats que ça devienne les précédents
lauréats mais écoutez chacun fait son
parcours
on a d'ailleurs vu par exemple peut-être
une sale week-end connaissait qui a été
lauréat de la catégorie humoristique en
2012 qui maintenant
perth bien dans le métier nous avons eu
monsieur samuel fayyad qui a aussi
remporté
la catégorie économie en 2012 qui
actuellement est une entreprise
actuellement en ville voilà donc en fait
que ce soit des nominés que ce soit des
lauréats faut savoir que chacun en
continu dans son parcours et évoluent en
fonction certains réussissent et nous en
sommes heureux